[Musique]
c'est déjà tellement dur de faire tes
premières sorties en boîte à paris c'est
tellement dur c'est le pire endroit où
débuter cette activité le pire si l'on à
paris à des physios cdc les mecs à
l'entrée là ici c'est si les enfants de
satan d'accord je pense si moi je pense
pas qu après ils rentrent chez eux
je prends ce qu'ils prennent un hubert
qui le ramène directement en enfer c'est
ça mon avis c'est ma théorie à moi
d'accord dit que quand je le vois chaque
fois qu'il me regarde
j'ai l'impression qui connaît un truc de
mon passé et et qui m'en veut pour ça
j'ai à peine de le rencontrer il a déjà
du mépris pour moi si ça raconte je suis
là pour quoi pour qui ça raconte ça que
j'ai pris cela raconte et explique man i
les physios son travail se dire oui et
non il a les mêmes compétences qu un feu
rouge
qu'est-ce que
je sois sympa avec nous d'accord non tu
peux nous parler correctement on est en
ald est juste par le nom correctement ce
tout ce que je demande maintenant mais
peut-être que c'est moi excuse moi
peut-être que c'est moi une fois on m'a
respectée je me suis habitué
peut-être que c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]